hi fandango it's me marcela shell shoes
on here's a behind-the-scenes look at me
and my new movie martial show
i'm sorry i should have said that
already i'm a little nervous i'm not
used to all this promotional stuff you
know i don't know from a technical
standpoint i'm like really eager to show
people the lengths that we went to on
stage because i think you just would
never assume watching the final film but
that's how that was done every single
object that marcel interacts with has to
be recreatable and animatable the couch
for example you have to shoot that couch
and then you have to take that onto an
animation stage and essentially gut it
and fill it with materials that look
exactly identical but can be animated
these characters are real small so they
don't have any weight when the
characters jump down and they land on
that seat
something has to push them into the
ground so what we've done is we've
created an apparatus that sits in the
sofa cushions that an animator can then
pull down and push up and we have maybe
35 points on each cushion to be able to
push up and pull down
[Applause]
[Music]
you